quitte à rêver au maintien tant les
clients toi 3,6 il raconte ses terres et
moi j'ose que prendre le métro les
femmes ont changé c'est pour croyable
maintenant on se croit tout permis
tentant de ces choses dans le métro mais
c'est vrai les jeunes ouvrières tous
avec leur musette sur l'épaule bon ça
passe encore et envoie des bobards ce
gars là pour passer la nuit avec lui je
n'aurais bien tous mes tickets de
cantine
bon c'est pas méchant mais les pires
c'est les vieilles elles sont sûres noir
les vieilles elles tricotent comme ça
puis d'un seul coup elle te balance une
noyade [ __ ] du nom moi je sais plus
où m c'est vrai on m a dans le lait trop
bas il faut se méfier de tout le monde
dans le métro passe même du personnel
l'autre jour dont j'étais en première
j'avais pas menti qu'il ya une
contrôleuse qui monte à billets ouais
c'est confus gelée par madame même en
été c'est la prison qui a fait quelle
autorité saha le prestigieux l'uniforme
forcément alors elle voyait que j'étais
plaire du tout moment j'étais rouge de
confusion alors elle me tapote la joue
comme ça gentiment elle fait masser à
rien monter ça va s'arranger
effectivement il ya personne dans le
wagon ça s'est arrangé pour 2 francs 20
j'avais honte quand même c'est vrai mais
dans le métro les pires c'est les femmes
d'affaires voyez les femmes d'affaires
le tailleur strict pour aller pour aller
du chantier au bureau tu vois la
coiffure toute en ciment pour que ça
tienne toute la journée alors celle là
c'est les pires d'une main elles lisent
le point et valeurs actuelles puis de
l'autre ils font le point des valeurs
moi je te lis et non mais j'ai des bleus
partout
l'autre jour quand j'étais avec raymond
je connais raymond on avait fait du
shopping à propos on a trouvé des petits
pulls ravissant très très joli ce nom
c'est vrai parce que raymond il connaît
toutes les bonnes adresses sa femme est
avocat a forcément ils reçoivent
beaucoup ils sortent beaucoup obligés de
s'habiller à moi quand j'étais là
j'avais tous mes paquets non mais c'est
vrai on achète trois fois rien ça fait
tout de suite du volume alors j'étais là
je mets mes paquets j'arrivais pas
ouvrir la porte et ya une femme
d'affaires c'est le genre candresse
supérieur qui arrivent et qui me fait je
peux vous aider monsieur
moi tout de suite merci madame c'est
vrai j'aime pas qu'on m'aborde devrait
alors après je me dis dans le fond pour
une fois que tu tombes sur une clé
serviable un effroi qu'elle avait mes
paquets dans la main je vais tranquille
bon elle m'a raccompagné jusqu'à la
maison dit non elle voulait monter sa
culot en moi je dis non à cause de mon
père il est sévère
eh ben je vais retrouver tous les matins
devant ma porte
avec sa jaguar et son chauffeur son show
furent lucienne je veux pas la voir et
me regarde avec un petit air méprisant
je me demande pourquoi il me prend pour
un traînée elle prend pour entraîner
aussi pourquoi moi j'ai jamais accepté
un cadeau de sa patronne
non si j'étais moins bien je pars à des
fourrure des bijoux georgette madore
s'appelle georges et 20 par jour même
chez le coiffeur raymond shampouine il
rire il faut dire que lui les histoires
de femmes
enfin il vit avec gaston de manucure bon
pour en revenir à georgette l'autre jour
j'ai dit écoutez jean rède qu'est ce que
vous voulez m fait vous alors là
j'hésite projet laissez vous voulez
épouse et moi j'ai cru que j'allais
bondir et ben non elle est restée très
calme très calme très calme est l a fait
je vais réfléchir
depuis j'attends mais si un jour j'ai la
bague au doigt jean callet qui va être
drôlement jaloux 1
c'est benoît welters et tous mes copains
du rugby et ont offert une de ses têtes
ah bah tiens il vendit à pouvoir
rembourser